I'm pretty sure to you though you love
being murderer and you're all this is
true doesn't mean I always get to be the
murderer
all right let's do this
I'm innocent I'm bystander lies - I you
cannot possibly be the how the [ __ ] do I
get out of this thing
hey equal who is Delta hey hey cool
Delta hey wait I'm a pink Foxtrot if you
kill me
it's just like killing Bali oh here here
do you not a killer but here I got you
something Oh baby
wow thank you welcome for deterioration
train back to you Oh God suspiciously we
are you not are you not killing me I
can't wait a minute it's my sister
double it's your twin double aah oh my
god brigetta way to go you picked it up
kill kill kill kill kill kill don't ha
ha ha
zombie I can't believe he trusted me ha
ha zombie had me in a trapped in a room
with the gun out that whole time and you
look
why does zombie Josie you didn't say a
thing I'm trying to defend myself and I
am the bystander again but you're not
gonna believe me because it's you think
it's a logical but I believe it or
guzzle buddy' this or consider like I
gave him a baby okay this is fun as this
seems impossible
I am the bystander again please don't
kill me
Marc you at least have to be the
bystander with the gun no I am just
bystander no gun that is what I am
I promise who is I'm Zulu I if that's
Miko and he's no God oh god he wasn't
told you I was he doesn't have a ghost
away from me my screen is pitch-black
good I kill innocent bystander to stay
away from me well apparently a plane are
you yet again so you can see that I'm
not that the murderer right yeah so so
yeah now I can see protect me tango you
up that there he is oh there's the
killer area
the murderer there he is
okay damiana shing but i am once again
the bi-state kill me do not you have the
gun don't you no I do not Marx why I'll
add the price later without a gun don't
kill me
where are you I want to t-bag here are
you over here she kept up uh you old by
God you're moving too fast
everyone is going to die that way I
don't die all gonna be in separate
graves we have a 50/50 chance so killing
6 for coming out into the open it let me
kill you oh I had no idea zombie was
dead cuz he's so quiet
no I murdered him used to stand in a
closet I was like Betty's dead let moved
on zombie to scream or something hey
okay now it's astonishing but I am an
innocent bystander this time I am i dead
to start I didn't even see the game wait
a sec I saw black countdown instant
murder that's what you got instead of
zombies the murderer mark that means so
the murder is completely silent and
we're hosed
wait no Bob you're throwing blame around
a lot I don't like it yeah that's right
I you're right I am the murderer I
definitely want that to be on my
shoulders well he admitted it he's the
murderer so yeah wait mark which one are
you are you three shot is that you yeah
I'm in Dennett well he's over here he's
hiding in this room okay are you just
luring me into a trap
you totally not be trapping me ah I knew
it it was a trap
it was a dirty dirty truck oh my gos got
the gun yeah okay right over here is
cool those are let's go you just go
ahead I'll get up yep okay what okay
okay oh hey Mauro hey Mark and I want to
pick something up nice present
I'm gonna show you I just had it lined
up oh nothing
well the guns is some kind of weird
kitchen so I'm waiting here I'm just
I've gotta find some dry stuff and now
would you watch tiny stuff or not and
now I got ya why the lights out what's
happening a gun
wait what were you not telling me where
the gun was that it was in the kitchen
area which means nothing to me
yeah kind of does I don't know where it
is like the first floor subway it's so
cool the first floor I don't say higher
time I thought for sure you didn't have
the gun I did that time I know now I'm
dead we're okay I don't have the gun you
don't have to wait I don't have the gun
so you have something bad I don't have
anything I'm hitting all my numbers I
don't have anything I'll stand here all
right
shiny I brought the shining okay who's
that she's got shiny that's what that's
Bob who gets the shiny stuff you know
it's probably zona to me so that's a gun
Tommy's up there zombies up there top of
other dude he's coming down something
jump it down you trying to back to us
don't be failed zombie failed it
backstabbing us so he's going around
zombies hidin he's being shifted
reporting gunshots he's definitely
murdered thank you wants the street
yellow it okay all right I'm falling I'm
falling mark who are you I'm zu your
Zulu dude
all right here you too shiny stuff for
being a good lookout will you uh uh no I
have to all right it has to be on level
ground or I can't set it at your feet
thank you thank you
zombie hey zombie zombie ah Tommy let me
go ah oh that's not good
by this for coming convince us that Sami
was the murderer I didn't leave right I
was murdered and then you killed my are
you [ __ ]
well this is gonna end well and once
again it comes down to Zambian Bob
cuz I'm always murdered so his mom Bobby
you even saw what zombie was doing he
was trying to jump behind us he was
being shifty dodging gunshot and then he
ran away
Oh rad or so done also dead you deserve
it he's so dead you're so dead you're so
dead you're so dead you're so dead
you're so dead so dad
awesome so cool right yeah it's pretty
cool huh we actually Oh nice shiny I've
got this who's gonna be this [ __ ] I am I
am the winner of the shiny things
contest that is really good I don't
think there's a nice ending this entire
map there is no shinier thing what I got
another bus ha ha ha ha what about this
okay that's pretty good and pretty good
huh so uh so zombie mold loses yes I get
Lowe's and therefore he is in the river
right who has the gun kill him golf golf
is that zombie zombie golf I don't know
yeah he's golf yeah the guy who just
said had anything he's being shifty he's
being shifted again can he be zombie oh
hi guys oh you got one
there's the barber don't lose zombie you
don't lose here have my shiny stuff I'm
all the shopping echo take take it take
it you can have it huh Oh market tell me
when you had the chance which means it's
for Echo Tommy way just tried to ship
them onto me for no reason it's Echo
Jitsu Lo and I will let you shop